now astronomers are set to reveal what
they're calling a groundbreaking
development it's being presented right
now at news conferences in six cities
around the globe they're all taking
place at the same time this is the
result of years of work for the first
time scientists will be unveiling a real
image not just a computer animation of
one of the most mysterious objects in
the universe a black hole I'm joined now
by Leah AL breasts from DWS science desk
to talk about this with me more Leah
this is such a anticipated event how
significant is what we could potentially
be about to see it is it is huge really
I mean I was excited myself I dreamt
about this tonight and it's it's it's
really exciting because so far we have
only seen simulations about black holes
and this is now the first image we just
saw it and so it's it's you know it's
huge it was widely anticipated and of
course we can't see the hole itself so
because black holes are by definition
invisible but now we have an idea about
about you know the whole construct which
is for example in the middle and at the
center of our Milky Way and at the
center of many other galaxies and a big
big important point in our universe
which is still not fully understood now
haven't scientists known for a long time
what black holes look like I mean why
are these images such a big deal
no actually scientists haven't known
what what they look like they're just
simulations dead calculations they had
theories what they had were only
indirect observations so far for example
how stars move around some gravitational
really strong the center and they
thought that this would be the effect of
a black hole but there was there's no
real proof so far for exists for the
existence of a black hole now this image
is a proof and it's it's really it's
really huge it's bigger it's a big
and science history okay tell me a
little bit about the the teamwork the
international cooperation behind this
obviously this is this has been a sort
of a global science project to make to
make this happen what we're seeing today
yeah yeah with our teamwork it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be possible there are in
total a telescope so far that worked
together in different parts of the world
and they're all synchronized and time
very accurately with atomic clocks and
it only lose one second every hundred
million years so it's very accurate
worked and there there are telescopes in
Chile and Hawaii on the South Pole yet
the USA in Mexico and Spain eight in
total so it's a very important
scientific network and that works very
accurately to gather all those important
data okay well we're actually gonna go
live now to the press conference and to
find out more about what these
international scientists have got to
reveal the size of the distance between
these telescopes truly turning the earth
into a virtual telescope all the sites
that we use can be seen here we have
telescopes from Hawaii to Arizona to
Mexico to Chile to the South Pole in
Spain but even these even this broad
global network is not enough by itself
to make an image you can think of them
as being silvered spots and a large
global mirror the key is that the earth
turns during a night of observing we are
able to sweep out more baselines more
coverage of this virtual mirror to make
our image so on the left you'll see the
earth turning every pair of telescopes
provides us with one point on the center
panel which fills in the earth size
virtual lense and on the right you see
the evolving image the more and more
data we get the more we fill in this
virtual mirror the sharper our view of
the black hole becomes until you wind up
seeing what we have as the final image
there so we've taken advantage of a
cosmic opportunity it's remarkable when
you think about it light that left near
the event horizon traveled all the way
through intergalactic space
it hit our telescopes the earth just
happens to be the right size so we get
resolving power so that we can see the
black hole in m87 whose mass and
distance let us observe it and then the
earth turns to fill in our mirror so
that we can make this image it's really
remarkable it's almost humbling in a
certain way now we are four members of a
large collaboration and is our distinct
honor to be here to represent that
collaboration we are 200 members strong
we have 60 institutes and we are working
in over 20 countries and regions we
consider ourselves really to be
explorers through international
cooperation and innovation we've exposed
part of the universe that we thought was
invisible to us before it's our
responsibility now to report these
findings and we're doing that today to
the National Science Foundation to our
funding agencies International and
foundations and to all people who
support pioneering research and also to
the taxpayers nature has conspired to
let us see something that we thought was
invisible this is a long-sought goal for
us and we find it tremendous and we hope
that you will be inspired by it too
thank you and now let me introduce Dan
Maroney who has literally gone to the
ends of the earth to collect some of the
data that we've seen here today
[Applause]
thanks chef
so oh there we go
so the heart of our measurement is of
course the EHT array it would have been
an expensive enormous undertaking to
build a dedicated array just to do this
experiment so we didn't do that instead
we built an international partnership
that allowed us to use sub millionaire
telescopes all over the world in fact we
used basically all the submillimetre
telescopes in the world to make this
measurement one that none of them could
have done on their own when you take a
heterogeneous collection of telescopes
and build them into one giant telescope
it presents a lot of technical
challenges and so in the years leading
up to our 2017 experiment we went
telescope by telescope all over the
world
installing the specialized hardware we
needed to do this most of the telescopes
had detectors that we could use but
almost none of them had the atomic
clocks we need and certainly none of
them had the very fast data recorders
that we use some places we had to do
even more a good example of this is the
Alma telescope in Chile it's a 66
telescope array it's by far our most
sensitive telescope and its sensitivity
is transformational for our experiment
but in order to use it we didn't just
need the basic hardware we also needed a
special piece of hardware that could sum
the light from all the telescopes before
we sent it to our recorders this alone
was a many year project using an
international collaboration of people
from the EHT and also from the Alma
project another good example is the
South Pole telescope the South Pole is a
special place in our array it's so far
self that it doubles the resolution of
the ht4 sources it can see but the SBT
was designed to do a completely
different kind of measurement it studies
the Cosmic Microwave Background and so
it's detectors are not the detectors we
need so in addition to bringing down an
atomic clock and all the tens of crates
of hardware that we needed we had to
build a special receiver that would
detect the light the way we need it
detected
special optics to relay the light to it
and install it and get it to work in the
cold and sometimes harsh Antarctic
environment this was many years of work
for many of us many trips down for
myself and graduate students in postdoc
and other engineers in the EHT team but
at the end of it we had a South Pole
telescope that could be an EHT station
now alright now that was coverage from
Washington where science scientists were
announcing images very first images of
an actual black hole I'm joined by Leah
our pleasure from DW science desk so
Leah we just heard some some
extraordinary things there obviously a
large collaboration 200 members working
in 20 countries one of the scientists
speaking called it a humbling experience
this research that's happened and
exposing parts of the universe that we
thought were invisible incredible stuff
now the black hole by definition should
be invisible it's black and yet we now
have these extraordinary images how was
this how was this possible yeah first of
all you're right it is invisible a black
you can see a black hole what we can see
now antes he mentioned the name event
horizon that's what we see it's actually
if we imagine the black hole as a as a
as a hole and and we see around it we
see the swirling gases and and and dust
for example and that's what we see
actually so we see the shadow of the
black hole against the backdrop of dust
and gases that are orbiting around the
black hole about around this
gravitational Center that is so strong
that everything is drawn into it which
comes which goes beyond the event
horizon that's actually the point of no
return and after this point you don't
have you there's only dark there's only
darkness and no return so everything
which comes in there doesn't come out
again what about the what about the
technology behind this how complicated a
process has it process has it been to
pull this data together and make this
possible it has been really complicated
because first of all they needed a lot a
lot of data imagine if you want to
observe
black hole for example the black hole at
the center of our Milky Way it's it's
like observing it's a it's like counting
the individual dimples on a golf ball it
is four thousand kilometers away or else
two thousand five hundred miles it's
really far so what they needed to count
the stitute to get those signals is was
a really big telescope dish it would
need the size of Earth of course we
can't have a dish that's the size of
Earth so that's why they simulated this
size of a dish with different stations
with different telescopes and different
parts of the world as we saw on the and
the press conference as well but still
there are gaps
you can't without this big dish you
can't have all the signals that come
from the black hole now they have those
they still have those big data and they
try to put them all together they have
this big that you can't even transmit
them by internet just you know just as
an image you need to store them on hard
disks and ship them and ship them to the
supercomputer that then can analyze them
and can make up the image so it's it's
not a photo but it's an image made up of
big huge data that was gathered so far
right lea l brush from DW science test
thanks so much for filling us in on the
part of you the universe we thought was
invisible but now we can see